[Music]
what is up everybody happy Tuesday
pershing here
Jackie Tran is joining me he has been
playing Tekken for like ever and there's
a brand new character who's joining the
roster as of yesterday yeah yeah the
patch hit yesterday and the character
baccara became available today I believe
so yeah I'm excited to check it out
we're gonna hit the lab a little bit
jack Tran is gonna basically show us
what the characters about some of the
new stuff he's kind of crazy looking so
far there's already a bunch of cool tech
on Twitter we're gonna play some matches
with him today also they've even been
some balance changes and also a new
stage so we're gonna check it all out
thank you guys for joining us and yeah
let's do this let's put the game on boom
there we go let's get the chat up oh
snap perfect legend in the chat hello
how's it going all right you guys could
check out my rank I'm AB in the Kitty
room alright well we'll go over some of
the stuff she she mentioned as far as
what's new here is the new character
baccara man he's not only ripped but
look at all these tags I've been
watching letting quorums lately these
are so you some nice tats so a little
bit of the lore or the story behind this
characters that they first announced him
at the end of the 2019 second world tour
finals and they wanted the finals was
also in Thailand so this was kind of a
way for Namco and the game to get back
and show love for the show support for
the Thailand community so they had this
more type more Thai warrior world
champion a little bit of the lore I
think he got struck by lightning when he
was young like 12 years old and then he
became more Thai champion and 18 and you
know his got split away from his family
because the whole drama of
the tuck-in tournament so the nation
forces they sent him to the detective
King and Iron Fist tournament to
represent Thailand that's kind of the
lore on him a little bit we can also
check out his new stage so the new stage
is right here guys
yeah Cave them enlightenment so it's
pretty cool shows you guys like the
dimensions of the stage a little bit 1/2
B 1 and B 2 so 1/2 represents the first
floor B wanna be to being basement 1 and
basement to so there's a balcony break
on the first floor and there's also a
floor break on the second floor so mad
damage right you've seen it now it's
only a matter of time Freight happens in
tournaments yeah yeah shoutouts to PL
he's also a legend himself but thanks
for joining us what's up everybody else
also Brandon and Cyborg man
Damon RL what's going on guys thanks for
joining us see so yeah break it down
with this character real quick first of
all he's tall is yeah look his head is
almost you know wide apart I think they
just as high a little bit between when
they released him and when he came out
now so I think he's a little taller
yeah then what do you you know I get all
the Sagat vibes right now the bass to
God from Street Fighter L Street Fighter
and a dog maybe a little bit yeah you
know the muy Thai yeah this guy's boy ty
they also had the frame dead in this
game in the previous patch so that's
also something new so I have both turned
on for myself and then my opponent
okay and this is a completely new
character to the series right yeah
there's a lot of characters that are
like making their comebacks from older
games so they are already very familiar
so this is clean slate brand-new
character feel like you know when vegan
join Tekken 7 brand-new so they have
legacy characters which you know those
characters have been in seconds before
they also have original character so
walk around being an original character
that second is in nemco they created
Bruce is a character that they had
similar to this he was more of a
kickboxer so I know that second and then
code they talked about really showing
boy time what it's really about full
force so this character really shows
that so pretty cool we're gonna go over
some of his moves and maybe show the
little combos maybe you could teach you
a combo too and then maybe we can fight
some people after we're gonna be playing
online so we'll try to maybe set up a
lobby we're on PC I know Jackie Tran
here is fresh defeat PCs been playing on
ps4 online a lot but now you're in PC
world yeah we world been on PC for a
couple weeks now I'm really enjoying it
I know that second world tour is on
PlayStation but it's good to have PC
available for streaming and playing with
your friends know learning alright
alright so let's look at his rage on
pretty cool
cool oh he's like so tall that's all the
head in that replay this guy's so I
might be using some acronyms if you guys
don't know where I'll be using one two
and three and four
representing the buttons on the
controller or actual you know buttons in
the game so he plays on pad I played
this game on arcade stick though so like
for instance the rage art is down for at
three plus four wire which would
represent left kick and right cake so
yeah pretty easy it also you know raised
drive one
they tuned for that so we can actually
do the move
so this character is a little unique
compared to the other characters because
he actually has more than one race drive
most characters only have one race job
if she has three pretty crazy these are
actually I think it's the same yeah
rage water you have 1 & 2 or similarites
just start with your left starting with
the left leg and then the right leg but
this looks like very strong - it looks
like a minute - a big - alone so you
know what would be the main factor and
like which one you would decide to use
um I just take depends on which string
you're doing because some strings have
left kick in it and some have right so
they pretty much gave you the option of
doing the razor I've kind of both both
both feet yeah so it's really really
cool so you know so he might have a
string that has one two three it could
be one two three
crazy night or you might have a string
that's one two four and once you I cants
on this thing so it gives you gives you
options that's really what's in the
brackets is the range right then he has
a third one here you can just do
good job it's really good seen that IRL
also break the floor actually put it on
block so we could see what it is
it'll pass
[Music]
Wow
so it's +1 on block which is really good
pretty much means that it's safe if
you're not familiar frames me saying
that is +1 on block means that it's
gonna be my turn or you know I'm at +1
frame advantage after the movie blocked
therefore my opponents blocking as
they're at minus 1 frame disadvantage
there's two rays dr3 let's go over some
of his strings one one that's up kitty
just trying to find the one that I like
that are really good one to do very good
a lot of character in the game 50 name
is there a Twix once it went for 53
damage combo die as I add in the chat
says Jackie check out back forward for
ya it's sick backboard for kick
so bocharov has what you would call
maybe like a guard crush which a lot of
characters most of the characters in the
game don't have so it's also something
new that they've implemented with him in
this game and to move that you just
explain to me to try to do does that so
kind of knocks back +6 right so
just move and I kind of like wow it
doesn't necessarily put him on the wall
but other moves that he has in this day
won't put him on the wall so it's really
strong I like characters in the game
don't have this but he has it +6
the moves also really good could you get
a combo off of it
it is a high it is a high which weed you
could duck it and most high blues are
safe mid was being more unsafe
well yeah backward for there you go and
if his strong moves keep going
thunderstorm combination I like this
also very fast its tech frames which is
no a fittingly the fastest attacking the
game
yeah being 10 frames so yeah before head
string that starts with dad like that
so all the characters have kind of like
what they would call carrot canceling
our moves that come out and they cancel
into other moves and more tight has a
lot of that and they make a [ __ ] I'm a
lot of that so this is one of the first
Clues moving this that we're checking
out here so I'm looking at tips I bring
in the chats like how's Hollis he feels
I just look it up is over six seven
eight yeah you might be the tallest I
don't share how tall bark is but he's
pretty girl he's like this a got a
second yeah pretty much
I definitely
so here he has a for his string right
the first three hits is one two four and
the last part being parentheses it's a
partly kind of like he's cancelling the
low kick into the punch Tigers gaze okay
so I was talking about his crushed got
crushed property so he's a good example
the first version is just a regular
fourth combo but he has the same moves
but if you hold it yeah does more damage
launches them but I think the big part
about that they're between 10 and 11 is
when they're blocking actually stop what
they're blocking you're gonna crush
their guard but you have an opportunity
to interrupt them that deal right that's
kind of something new not a lot of
characters have and this game down he
has something new exciting to check out
super cool King Bruce so this character
right right so earlier I mentioned that
he was similar to Bruce but Namco was
trying to show off you're trying to show
that the true multi my style you know
and Bruce was more of a [ __ ] so
I feel like with baka ramen they really
did that boy tiny thing to pull this
with himself Shasta Bruce I mean they
did my style they look similar but this
guy is original as it gets each big I
got that we got the Muay Thai
full fight stance that Bruce didn't have
you know just a little little kickboxer
and you know back then when he was on
second you know this character to have
as many wounds were sitting down so yeah
if you look at the mouthless like
literally a hundred items on the list
it's insane this game faces somebody so
many things rest limits are it says
bullet Club for life noise and the way
to share it for you guys today I also
like the string a lot its high high I
look
but the lowest hard to react to it very
fast this drink at least is the lab say
all three high oh yes
although you don't have some streams
that are like this these seems like a
guessing game when you see it but I mean
like this pretty well first already and
so now I keep the opposite spot a rocker
on guys
I like jab high kick
Ted brave very strong I like this also
[Music]
we have two for threes also very strong
full frame so what do you think about
this character so finally what do you
think his weaknesses are um I'm not sure
it's still kind of early um one thing
I've noticed that he doesn't have done
other characters have is like a actual
standing launcher you know so he's more
of like a counter hit type character
where he for him to launch you a job you
has he has he hit me while you're
hitting play whereas all the characters
can they have like standing launchers or
if you whip a button they can launch you
all right him he might not be able to do
that yeah so instead of getting a yeah
so instead of getting combo you might
get like two or three hit string which
still does a lot of damage she knows
laughs instead of you getting a juggle
you might get a knockdown or more
advantage yeah so it's more of the boy
type iced I know
these commas and they're not even strung
together yeah so chat is saying they
want to see some some Jumbotron goes
what are we okay well they actually have
sample comas on here that are pretty
good you guys want to see one all right
sample combos sample combo one two three
being I think the easiest difficult in
order it actually shows you the damage
on here is really cool all new features
have taken added to the game so yeah
that's a ticket for really trying to
reach out to players and help them learn
the game where the longest time ii
didn't really show much so it's really
just like here's the game here's
practice mode go at it so i'm excited
but also so we can learn this sample
copper one first let's see what it's
going alright
that easier combo but it's triangle
fascist so yeah dump forward Right punch
left kick we have board one one four
back four three two so I like to break
down calm with sometimes you know learn
learn each Park is trying to be trying
to learn if we try to learn the whole
combo and once it could be getting
difficult you could get stuck on a park
so instead I like to break down combos
into sections which they kind of already
done a little bit and once you master or
learn each section of the combo and you
progress the Cobo gets a little easier
yeah we're gonna happen to some online
matches in a bit we're just showing off
kind of way what this has and I'm just
letting you guys know what is gonna you
know what's expect from this character I
guess he's brand new he just came out so
I mean I haven't really seen much of him
at all yet but I know there's already
tons of check out there cuz Twitter's
fast online is fast and I mean guys
that's already in the tower right now he
knows a lot about this character too so
yeah alright we'll do one hard hard
combo and then we'll jump into ranked
battles
all right we do sample combo nine
yeah launching for Fargo punches okay we
need to like break the floor the wall
huh
[Music]
how do you say this again Matilda yeah
[ __ ] well still DS so be prepared to
be sliding with this character all right
so there's [ __ ] rom and the new stage
Damon says are using stick or controller
I'm using a controller currently going
up up jonn's how's it going I play a
boss
I just thought stick might be a little
loud for this dream but controller
controller is what I'm using right now I
mean for me personally whenever I play a
new character in this game it takes me
like a minimum of like a week before I
feel comfortable enough to go online but
you got it I believe in you oh you're
gonna beat up on the old the old new
character really Smith Leroy he's the
character came out before foie gras
we've had a couple changes already he's
only been out for a few months our first
opponent first maybe will open up a la
boeuf connection people open up a lobby
soon I know you probably have people on
your friends list who would like to play
also maybe people in the chat want to
play if you guys want to add me you guys
see my name on the screen so maybe you
can shoot me an invite and maybe we can
play some
Challenger
also let me know if everything sounds
okay in terms of the game audio because
we have it down low a little bit on our
end but seems like no one's having me
issues yet so yeah
in between matches we'll we'll try to
demonstrate some stuff if we have time
fight
okay Mira Bradford so we'll definitely
be able to see some things Oh No chat
was mending things needs kinda like
Josie and I get those bikes from that
kick yeah I guess I forgot about Johnny
too so people thinking that you know we
might not get bruised because we have
Josie this is the full price of like new
characters coming out is everyone's
trying them out everyone you know give
it an overall you see new tech or
different things or what they find
practice is practical in the match also
please excuse the 32.5 second stream
delay between when we dare you guys
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I like that though it looked like he was
whipping the string but he is actually
letting the last hit and miss Chang Qing
yuan wake up with his leg in ready first
team on the strands favorite character
to use in this game is Jack seven that's
his main character but he knows maybe
after today yeah I don't know actually
who is your favorite character to play
because I know Jack's here mean but you
know I see you have fun with those
characters like Jin I don't know I have
a bigger character I know but Jack is my
tournament character that I've been
using over the years so I don't know who
my favorite character is it's a good one
I like them all that's a true second
player would see someone mentioning Aris
in the chat guys if you're not super
familiar with tech today you do want to
watch
get familiar players and people in the
community and who should be watching at
this time Eris is definitely one of
those people obviously Jackie trans are
those people
we've got Anakin as well very awesome
Guardian a lot of cool people we get
them check out poke cha I know he was
very very adamant about this character
being out especially since he was a
Bruce player right oh yes so yeah yeah
that was 80 ounces nothing like to Sagat
and characters beating the crap out of
each other too hard techno dub dub
Freddie life stuck in in a nutshell
right there I love the sound right in
this game I think all the songs are
really good
these suck me a lot
[Music]
yeah it's not so pretty and seeing leg
wall the wall double time without his
character absolutely I'm st. carry
really cool I cannot wait to see what
kind of shenanigans will come up with
his character especially cancel
I'll date got offstage spoken with dirty
feet
hug him his proportions I believe super
weird but but it's cool
I know we get people all over you magic
- yeah you know most people run out on
this mom
this is uh whenever you using new
character your Frank is like from the
start reading stuff I feel like the
lower ranks are more willing to like
play the higher ranks like I don't want
to lose the points I can get out of here
oh it's so crunchy every hit hurts
Dornan he's starting to adapt some of
your techniques over know number three
that French definitely gives me and I
think it's because he has like the
little jacket on his character right now
theme food says I'm an on a second
player but I just [ __ ] this guy as a
big boys night for years and can't
resist it as a boring player how closely
matched are they I heard a whole wrong
got bumped a lot in this new patch too
so we'll see Oh
as far as um kind of similar actually
cuz all Castle cancels so Taekwondo
cancels I'm not sure who's quicker
that's of no word that's um that's like
a paper number thing with brain stuff if
you want to compare to to fight styles
I'll talk one note in white I know a
baccarat I'm probably using a little bit
more punches at home alright more feet
what have the kids
when you play the character two more
prepared fruits as well
the search string that was close I'm
distracting you a little bit that's okay
fruits is wearing got buff best patch
ever
some people were saying that some people
are saying this is a good match I'm in
school early to say but uh from what
I've seen so far I like it
do I know the Dragon Ball casts um like
this show or talking about fighters or
the casts of commentators that are gonna
have to narrow that one down but all in
all like the time so fighters I have a
general idea when it comes to the show
it's like I know by association but I
really watched show like that
Lewis has question for you he says do
you think Tekken the Tekken team will
make it season 4 yeah I do you look at
the character select screen hit a whole
Rolex don't missing it so I'm not sure
what characters will be on there but I'm
hoping so but I wouldn't be surprised
that they did because this game is gone
such a long way vanora
for a new iteration every few years
already
Oh Victor we aren't playing yes the most
fighting games don't last as long as
this game yes you know no don't either
make a new one or maybe a newer version
of it but I feel like this game
definitely still has some good years
left it's like would you rather have
check an eight or more ticket seven
right it ain't broke don't fix it
everybody's been happy with it I know
these hold a lot of copies of it D I'll
see you good that corner was not the
place to be my favorite character is the
FINA that's who I'm using that's my name
right now cuz you know super cool she's
so creepy DP and I love that rolling all
over the place dances
I'd be a different stream obviously I I
actually liked Street Fighter cross
Tekken and I you know I'm not very good
at it but it was fun and I liked that
tag aspect of it and I liked having sex
and then I remember when that had first
came about they we're gonna do the
opposite Tekken cross street fighter we
never got it but when they put a cool in
this game I was like oh we need this
game I'm still ready for it so whenever
that comes about I'm ready for it
in the meantime I'll still enjoy second
seven I think I think what they did is
they were working on the game and they
kind of look took a little break gonna
kiss yeah cuz you know I wouldn't put
all my attention on this i have street
fighter came out first and then second
and then Soul Calibur if you think about
it
Akuma it Street Fighter 4 Akuma in this
game so yeah maybe who was the model for
whatever the game would be like maybe i
cou may is the test
Brentford second costume fighter the
feeling needs nerves no no she does him
she means buffs actually yes this is her
best game no don't nerve my character
please don't do them begging them the
sonic fox play second he says and he
plays Athena well last I saw he was
using me actually made like he made top
16 at a big tournament along Joe I think
it was easy drow you made top 16 that's
pretty good
they're definitely not at the level in
this penis is in every other game he's
playing but he just started but he
definitely I seen Aventine and playing
his first fighting game was actually
Soulcalibur for so he's he's familiar
with the 3d fighting world but you know
he just won Mortal Kombat so he's a
little bit you know stuff
who is very character you with one
season for not sure um they brought back
a lot of the legacy character stats that
were ending in the game but he didn't
have yet so I know who I would pick was
the name of that kangaroo Roger Roger
Roger Dodger be cool
I think Roger was just a pallet
round three I still can't get over how
hollow this character played me
characters I mean I play second when I
was a kid but that was you know I didn't
even realize that that was the game I
played until years later when I joined
FTC and IOC second I will say honestly
this does feel really familiar I played
all like the animal characters while I
did was like Mac ones like my brother
Jackie is trash at school girls
[Music]
hopefully you guys have ever see me play
no I've seen you play me I just liked
easiness yeah I tried to get him to play
my fighting games you can't beat all so
what is the character I feel like she's
got a headband with lakeshore Jun is
part of the storyline they have asked on
there but Jun is part of storylines she
that could be a character that can be
big
I mean why not yeah doing mom Jun the
kangaroo shinpachi he's kind of like the
boss boss he's Hayashi she's dead boss
characters I don't know how I feel about
boss
yes on the other screen between the
combination of anyone else like sci-fi
and anime gamer he's a little too
obsessed with the story of seconds I
think there's no such thing especially
when they're meeting
what country do you want represented
Lewis says he would like to see you can
ignaty in a Cameroonian or south african
character south african character or a
British woman I love this range heavy
agree with on mocha Jim I think it's
mixed about Bogut in some people who
would like to see him equal it is like
an old British woman who was also like
you know I'm like some Yoda stuff but
she's super old but she's also like
super add down Michael kick your ass
original character idea for free right
there he guys cows to Michael Mary in
her Odyssey you guys are listening but
yeah you guys if you want to give a
Jackie Chan oh follow their answers to
their handle we're not signing off
beyond she's still got we're only
halfway through stream right now but
chat was asking about some Twitter
action and there you go got o connection
was lost she was fine worse
but about that green demon looking guy
back in the old days the ogre guns -
ogres I never were my main characters
for a while my first started playing
yeah they could come they could making
the parents I'm trying to think how they
would fit them in the lore but yeah I
would not be surprised I would actually
like to see more diverse characters from
other games being brought at second like
they've been doing cool boy they did a
great job geese did a great job
negan super cool you know knock this is
cool from Final Fantasy so maybe like a
deal a character or like a Soul Calibur
character or same way should I care
something like that because they bought
they've already implemented character
Persia demotion FIFA race said if they
didn't I'd knock - if they wouldn't eat
oh well you know why not people would be
pretty cool oh my goodness Brandon on my
Animal Crossing adventure it is well
underway I'm having so much fun with
game I'm very very excited
Daniel Jackson Tran has probably been
going to Texan tournaments long room and
maybe some of our viewers have been
alive and that's not even if you mean
that just like truth and tournament
you've probably seen how the terms of
seven balls from like going to the iCade
and playing it's embarrass you going Evo
yeah I feel like I'm a hybrid because
I've been playing through all the airs
almost okay I came from the arcane era
I'm everybody go verse up a minute
consoles they got rid of the arcade and
then you had to deal with you know
arcades and other countries getting the
game years before it came to console no
watching through the window I'm funny to
the Millenial era think she's trying to
do her knee - well yours had kind of the
heights the priority height of image
works at every game
I'll play it
your second husband Oh
oh man I don't know I feel like all my
love is for wife yeah she's waifu for
sure yeah I come back let's go the face
tat though it's real like ants the scar
on his face and he was like you know
what tat the other side even in our
culture Johnny Cage or grey fox in the
Tekken series I feel like I could see
Johnny Cage in this because he's not as
outlandish as some of the other like
like he is in in terms of personality
but I think like his kid is not as I've
heard a lot of Tekken and work on that
crossover talk that would be cool I
don't know if those two worlds could
ever actually feel like Ed Boon and
Parata LOV that would be epic that would
be epic that's like what the dreams are
made of
don't expect me to pronounce anything
correctly you guys let's just mash up
every single fighting game into one I
thought that was moving yeah but like
for real like an actual game yeah I
remember this fighting game on sega
where you can fight with cars yeah like
it was like a Sega fighters all-star why
not even like some of the cars from like
one of the reason use animals
oh yeah it's true there's obviously Lake
Point so many things that are stopping
certain key partners this ring is I'm
sure if only everything is simple
is this not sick Oh drop it
wait you have life to get this one you
think it's over it's like
ground for virtual pioneer man seeing
all of this you're fighting him back in
the chat is very nice I like it
Richard Potter might be in a one
fighting game that's hard to detect
I mean after I saw liquid chameleon
since I thought bloody war was coming
back
I mean after Samurai Shodown game that
I'm like I'm ready for anything
everything can come back
[Music]
yeah oh man I feel like he's trying to
set you up the style on you right now
don't load it up and oh that should have
been your demise definitely not swerving
on your L if you would have died for
that oh my god oh my god she wasn't so
convert you
you're humid sue is also in both what
character would I like to see there no
drop back everybody almost Oh rave had a
good question as cool as the guest
characters in second are what are
attacking character is gonna be guess
when other games when are technicals
gonna be guest on other games yeah
that's um
I can see a smash brother may be sure I
don't know if there's a thing with
nintendo and Namco smash could be one of
the games I could see well if they do
like a like a Sony Playstation to
all-star game like they did before
oh he was upset now he's like no like
I'm not about to be and his like jet
upper just makes the head pop off
completely that would be robots
yeah however Brides first and you know
they have videos for the story mode show
him coming out and all these tanks
military and he just splits in half I'm
like oh my gosh you're so half-man
half-robot
play a lot of games
I feel like competitively I play card
games really well like I'm round legend
on medic medic medic at arena the mythic
for every month since I download it link
maybe three or four months ago
hearthstone also like that I like mobile
games like League of Legends hey ran
stuff like that I also like sports games
you know like NBA 2k mad and I like
shooters to new Call of Duty was always
fun a tech legend you know yeah she's as
far as 1v1 goes she wins but I still
love also like like adventure games like
The Last of Us 2 is a game woman - [ __ ]
- Oscar said that he just grow a couple
more feet of non-soy dollars yeah
actually if you look at the picture this
one the new one and like if you look at
the picture of the release model of him
I think he's growing up the assistant
he's a girl boy you know you made a
bigger maybe one season Parkins out his
face would just be off the screen I'll
just be from the neck down Cole Carine
says Magic the Gathering full of the
wind in
yeah I'm happy that game is growing a
lot
he just had like a two million dollar
prize for the world so in Hawaii it pays
to be a nerdy days of playing games now
it's cool might check out room Tara Tara
turns out to be strong but I know Ryan
is backing the games - or is making the
game yourself yeah I like I just am like
my energy is so bad for car games that's
my only downfall for like alright to try
to take over you know slowly well it's
working they got all these games like
for every genre now practically I am
super hyped to see project that like two
seconds long snippet that they showed
off in the 10 year League anniversary
thing I still think about it see how
it's gonna be
oh we've got another character selection
[Music]
exactly a cosh take that that's a fake
it for me fun me this using a ps4 pad
[Music]
three
[Music]
noise see no one block their legs
Brandon I am not sure yes but you guys
are curious about community Friday and
you've been playing animal crossing then
and jumbly are gonna be opening up their
island for later this week but yeah so
finalized
it's like a mix-up because they kind of
hit it up simple but effective mixes
like mix ups with the same but he didn't
you brought it all the way that just
said Nora I'm brown so happy like this
how I motivate I just talk a bunch of
trash hello from Greek quarantine
well hello hope you're staying safe out
there we are also you know under
lockdown here in San Francisco that's
why you may have noticed that all of the
GameSpot live streams for the past week
or so have also been from our homes even
you know John lives and been molding the
downstream eating Fridays as well so
yeah thank you for tuning in hope all is
well and hope everybody else on the chat
is staying safe and sane during this
time cuz I know at least for me it's
it's a bit nerve-wracking as much as I
do want to say in forums like
so that's why I like that we can come
and hang out with you guys and still
play games and just get our minds off
that for once but it doesn't change back
that still hoping is the best for
everything right now
um I mean whenever it comes to me
playing online with people I usually
just use my account
any guy went to me like that
but I also don't mind like sharing my
usernames and stuff with you guys which
- you're part of our community and you
guys are pretty much like my friends so
why wouldn't I let you have access to my
username and stuff like that to you so I
think that's kind of how everyone feels
about it and we on our end
oh my gosh yeah playing a halflife at
like yesterday I thought I really I hear
something sounds like it was for me I
really really loved it but certain games
I know
oh snap
el chingon just started playing at
Bethenny's that shot
it's like snooping all up on your
friends let's say don't worry
oh you're gonna knock him down the
stairs I wouldn't have saved it okay
I'll dance for you you know how like
Obama had his anger translator
I'll be your celebratory translator cuz
this guy here he's won all these
tournaments and he played all these
people what
you know that all mad so when he gets
winds it's not exciting for him meet you
on the other hand I don't care if I win
a million tournaments if I get that dog
yeah you already know this gotta be
excited for yourself you know
nice I'm pretty sure well my huge name
is usually purchase XO unlike everything
but there are a little bit different on
certain things like one of them might
have an underscore or it's Persia EXO
with no space or crazy stuff like that
so think on PlayStation it's definitely
/ - EXO no space steam is like Persia
underscore EXO not even gonna try to
share my switch code because I think
it's like 50 bajillion million likes
fulfilling in numbers long easy
seems like everyone's enjoying this
character at least enough to play online
though we ran into a few now d1 anyone
you're gonna see a lot of line
these for a week or two tightly aligned
your boy figures a map do you think he's
on Leroy levels where you know the next
tournament we see we're gonna have seven
out of the eight I don't know ever see
that again moment of time it happened a
lot of people kind of force all that
happening or something close to that but
not at that magnitude but I'm also a
marble player and I definitely see what
you get the high level and there's a
meta game established that you know
you're gonna see stuff like that at that
level people just want to
take that pride home in the trophy yeah
I don't feel like people are no I mean
even our salon - plays more than one
character you know me one of the best
players when not anybody to do that
[Music]
waiting for like the fattest lunch well
yeah well let him have that one we
transfer that's Oh rain to liquid
chameleon say who's the person that won
a tech and turning room with only panda
well I think he didn't you play pound
all the way through what a most part I
mean there was like one match where he
used someone else but it was for like
match up yeah I mean he may be the
switched from kuma go in the Panther
which is almost same character yeah I
did come on kitten and panda have like
different head hurt he would just switch
from one bear to the other depending the
matchup but yeah he won the world tour
with panda range here even her honor
have to turn him he was like Panda Yeah
right
um infinite as you - that is my favorite
page you like the music I love the music
and I love the way it looks it's a very
aesthetically pleasing like if you were
to see my wallpaper and now it almost
looks like infinite Asher it's like a
purple Gallagher baby like the first one
better one to pursue one maybe just a
music fight oh yeah
whoa
hitting them in the back the spine Damon
said follow-up question you you use the
d-pad or the analog stick to control the
characters I use the d-pad when I play
on play on controller I think using the
analog on a pad is pretty crazy
but you can do it second way allows it
Texas is one of those games where it's
like you know they say knowing is half
the battle I feel like knowing is more
than half the battle in this know like
extend it out with it what that tech see
that's what be getting me another theme
as a 2d fighter where you know that
armor that linen is out there and I see
my supers nine times is just on the
deceiving with the recovery
[Music]
yeah that's my favorite thing about
using arcade stick is button matching Oh
Sam Anika's online now we have about 15
minutes left of the stream today and of
course you guys if you want to see more
Tekken action check agendas stream
Tekken over on his stream there's a lot
of other cool Tekken streamers that are
on a lot especially you know now with
everyone being on lockdown and work from
home in most areas so yeah now no better
time than now to watch some Tekken David
said I love watching any Borobudur that
sounds so personal like probably not the
only one a lot of us growing up playing
Tekken and then eddy gordo got released
you know you don't want to lose to that
one person just mashing the kicks arcade
you know
effing jammers playing Eddie thanks you
see a lot of back and forth here on how
we feel about Eddie in the chat with its
emotions about a bordo Tim again eddie
gordo has you know the capoeira by style
you know so if it's kind of like you
were talking about I really like you
know you got to know so and this matchup
you can typically got enough yeah where
else you know your feet might be getting
hit a little bit very unique bites down
we still got a long time going down
where you don't even play plenty of
matches but yeah if you got here late
don't forget we're here every single
weekday at 2:00 p.m. that's what we go
like every single weekday so finding Lee
today and you enjoyed hanging out and
come back tomorrow we're gonna be live
again and of course ago you got content
going out we have a lot of Awesome
podcasts that we have of everything on
the YouTube channel
[Music]
such cool stuff even under these
freezing circumstances that we really
want to get checked out
[Music]
oh snap skill driver of darkness says my
first Tekken is Tekken 3 in my favorite
care I like that taken forth right in
second for Jim was Jackie's fate his
main character in he one evolution that
year that character so shadow see you
skill driver yeah fight he was really
good at take a 3 also vit check it for
he kind of took a new persona you know
he started wearing the hoodie and
started doing American karate instead of
like the traditional Mishima my style
kind of came in his own idea and you
know I really became the poster boy in
the game
you know the other chickens he had you
know he wasn't in the taken for a check
up to a second-story light years between
second four and three and two I'm not
quite sure you could have been looking
definitely kazuya's son
Hulk said his for a second a second to
play default Phoenix all one of the few
original one of the few characters have
been all the tech Mina yeah a few you
did one of them all that's like my one
fun trivia fact that I know about
anyone remembers artist author of the
report but that's mainly because I play
a lot of are looking and wearing it
I learned her award three Marvel 300
that are you he can't dance anymore you
brother play last round
Oh
sometimes I feel like Eddie's moves with
you more damage to himself
[Music]
did I get the Rose this is a long time
ago this was before they had like major
sponsors I mean did they it will
actually no what year was that
mm oh boy I didn't get a whole lot it
was mainly for pride play for play for
pride back then in a title we didn't
play for money back then well money in
terms of like the type of cash prizes
you see nowadays but what did I get for
winning oh yeah it was definitely you
think you took everybody out to dinner
after you win yeah everybody to Chinese
buffet after after the tournaments all
his friends all the homies all my
winnings some of it which i think is
nice some of it I think I can't want to
be a couple of bucks one man oh I don't
know if um somebody in the chat earlier
was saying they made boring yeah all
right guys to buff buff buff buff banner
player this season three patched and you
are going to love it
he was so cool he was the original Bob
for poor Bob Negro they used to call
[ __ ] on Bob the acronym bo-beat Bob's
ever boy on bike
Oh hold that take this day one character
got 700 to a girl that I see 11 wins
women said - [ __ ] around would destroy
cigars inside your shots though I'm just
saying you guys never see those videos
where one character is finding another
yeah yeah you know like the crazy ones
you know a few other ones that were cool
- they had like
yeah there's like Wolverine versus
somebody can we see Jackie play his Mane
for one match will still play a few more
[Music]
are you liking the new updates with the
I knew somebody boy I do it I don't I I
first he could play the Mishima so I
think it's cool and I've throughout the
years they've had some games where
they've always been they've been like
the number one are the best so they just
haven't been the number wasn't the best
in this game until maybe now I like the
changes that they did soil I'm not the
one to complain because the machine is
are the hardest about the hardest
characters to play in the game and they
take a lot of excuses maybe it's kind of
like an Akuma thing like yes you're
powerful but it takes some skill to do
it especially had a high level of it
thank you guys before for you guys yeah
I've heard some super hot tastes about
the Mishima update from a few players
around the community so yeah most people
who are complaining about they can't
even do this stuff so it's fine
you know the buffs that they actually
gave to them what they're not that
significant but it's enough where yeah
you might the players who are meaning
them oh wow
you don't see too many mickeymo plate up
there already because of the high level
of execution that it takes to play them
so that's why it's always Hank we need
to see people dislike but like you know
ketones is one of the few meteor players
but you've noticed you haven't really
seen them much or as well results lately
maybe we will now see certain players or
character get affected like yeah look I
dog he just won Capcom Cup with season 1
Laura no yeah he's been loyal to her I
mean you know he's been fiddling with
Tyson so that's good I think he needs
Ellis
that's definitely up the wind have a sec
okay
the time over the favorite I love it
sounds a Justin wall if it's one thing I
learned from to my buddy at the time is
your friend the clock is your friend I
don't know if you can do it as much in
these newer games but I think back then
those were more broken than they are now
so waiting you're pulling it out for
time again lightly actually following
optimal point a third of your life and
then like a quarter of your life on chip
yeah I remember one streetfighter
iteration or the team's about to be fine
to where Bisons chipped in more than
just justin wong me yeah it's five
seconds left
now you can just the money I'm waiting
Emily
I don't know my word ii would never have
been the same i mean they're part of the
storyline in the lord
they're like the characters i think her
first and i think a second oddly enough
they're like the ryu in the can i hate
on my back concerns do you fly out of
the corner with it
see sometimes you gotta use moves to get
you how to situation
oh yeah see this guy's smurfing me this
guys doing optimal combos on me at this
kid hog is not the easiest character in
there oh yeah I'm definitely getting
smoked food food we kick for every be
right up you trying to get real online
with it right now
all right here we go
[Music]
sorry I'm turning up on a per second I'm
not I'm not going down two rounds on
purpose guys it's turning out to be good
match Tekken force version you I want
interesting Tekken force is kind of like
the side scroller yeah that sounds fun
actually
yeah yeah I like I enjoyed the non
fighting game games that Tekken hands
like Tekken Bowl in these cool taking
balls cool ticket force which you
mentioned oh hey do not [ __ ] around that
sexy know how do we don't what because
he's already
the sightseeing lingshan Sagat
okay black he's definitely quick on the
you know when what's stranger this guy's
definitely smoking he's definitely not
warrior I can know I know it's I can
play it okay hey maybe he also has 700
at this level I was want to put a name
on him bowling taken ball I'm also a
second ball champion Jackie one second
ball tournament which combo also one
when it's strong stuff the most recent
ones though I bought all the previous
Tekken Bowl champions in that tournament
I beat a ball I'm the champion now so
funny reminds me of like Rose ball
[Music]
got a little tear that you know what's
up man taking ball champions represent
heals also attack it ball champion but I
be be off so I took a and Rick stuff you
two of the other attacker ball champions
and I did a fair character to Louis fire
on the ball and if he was a fire
[Music]
all right very nice very nice much um do
you want to play light one with the jaw
you don't have to if you don't want to
this is a [ __ ] rum stream but they
asked me to run it back run it back
oh no I think you talking about running
back in Tekken ball oh okay
bo you got it until then it's mine
I never run away from callouts run back
back happy about that
next take a tournament oh yeah I can't
wait until life calms down and we can go
to tournaments again good nerve inside
it's been they just postponed the
Olympics those these sports was about to
break dude I'm serious it's still like
these prizes in a great position right
now be created to know at least we can
solve online tournament sound like the
NBA
unless they're playing in be a 2k with
even more without imagine if they just
moved all of the NBA to online in the UK
and all the players had to play their
character in the game
another batch for that you're not using
oh yeah it's good it's high i like on
the first thing you did I'm not used to
it they used to have Bruce had this over
to no back door for a big need and you
could trust me a street fighter was
around second would be right up there
[Music]
chanted remind me one
now he's ready for you so we're talking
one weapon in the arsenal
one more thing has to worry about says
it's back for it easy to whip punish on
duck like with a wall or anything I
don't think so okay we're gonna fight a
lot I think we time I did it because I
was a hundred for ten tons I mean
infected but all right so let's wrap it
up here because that is all the time we
have for today but thank you guys so
much for tuning in stopping by checking
out the new character with us and just
generally hanging out and showed some
love for Tekken much appreciated hope
you guys had an awesome time and don't
forget every single weekday at 2:00 p.m.
we're still streaming here for GameSpot
live so do not miss out we also have
community Fridays being held down by
John Luke and Ben of course and this
Friday is gonna be Animal Crossing so
get prepared for that I've been playing
it a lot of fun um but yeah thank you
guys so much
if you'd like to give Jack trying to
follow there is his Twitter handle below
and he also streams Tekken 7 on his own
channel so if you want to see more of
him and you want to see more in second
then
you need to check out and of course
anybody else in the community who's
doing awesome second things you can find
yeah I mean other other members of the
community Aires to avoiding the puddle a
little Majin and again those are just
some of the big names and friends of
mine that are streaming full time right
now or mainly full time so check those
guys out if you guys want to check out
some checking action or learn a thing or
two or just come out and hang out with
us
yeah all right awesome look thank you
guys so much it's always great to see
the familiar faces and the new faces so
can't wait to see you next time until
then bye guys
[Music]